(upbeat music)
- Be the best you
you can possibly be.
My life is a testimony in itself,
and to speaking things into existence.
And you know, living the dream.
Content is king, content will always win.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
(laughing)
(whooshing)
- Hello Believe Nation,
I'm Evan Carmichael,
my one word is believe,
and I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all of
the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn
from actor and entrepreneur,
Nick Cannon, and my take on
his top ten rules for success.
Rule number five is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, as you're listening
if something really resonates with you,
if there's a message that
really holds true to you,
please leave it down the comments below
and put it in quotes so that
other people can be inspired.
And when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(whooshing)
(upbeat music)
- I'd always say,
I kind of give out the same advice
about one first being a self motivator.
Gettin' out there and
because there are so many
nay sayers, there's so many haters,
there's so many people that
going to say you can't do this,
there's so many people
who love to poke holes
in everyone's ideas
that you have to build
yourself up every day.
You have to be the one to say
no, this idea is brilliant.
This will happen, this is going to,
that, you know, speakin'
it into existence.
Be the best you you can possibly be.
And offer up what only you can offer up.
And you know, a lot of
people may mistake it
for arrogance, or conceit.
No, that's not what
we're talkin' about here,
we're talkin' about straight confidence.
Just sittin' up straight,
walkin' in a room, ownin' a room.
Demanding attention.
That's what it's all about.
You definitely have to be
delicate, and sensitive,
and professional at all times
when expressing your views,
and there's a time and
place to say certain things.
And you know, at times certain partners
may not agree with what I have to say.
- [Interviewer] Have
you ever run into that?
- Oh, all the time.
But you know what?
At the end of the day, I
tell people this often,
I'm not a role model.
I'm a real model.
A role is somethin' that you play.
If you want, you know, the
character that you may see here.
But the thing about bein'
real in every brand,
what every brand wants
to be, is authentic.
- Authentic, yeah.
- And that's who I am as an individual,
so yeah, you're not going
to agree with everything
I have to say.
You're not going to like everything I say.
But at the end of the day,
you're going to say he's real
to who he is, and to his community.
There are some great, wise
men in our community still
and I feel like people
don't take advantage
of tappin' into those resources of people
like Harry Belafonte, Sydney
Poitier, and Quincy Jones.
All of those type of
people who are still here,
have done it,
- Okay.
- Who have paved the way.
And have accumulate so much
knowledge and information,
and they have it,
and we just got to go in there
in and tap it and get it.
It's about the self generation,
you got to be a self generator.
And that's not waitin' for anybody.
You got to get out there
and do it yourself.
One of the reasons why Corey
Gunz is one of the hottest MCs
in the streets is because
he did it himself.
He didn't wait on a record label,
he didn't wait on somebody to come in
and say I'll take you here.
He just did it.
He would get out there,
and that's the mentality
of the young people today.
The millennials.
They just get out there
and they put forward.
And that's kind of how you
separate yourself from the pack,
whether it's with a mix tape,
whether it's with a demo reel,
whether whatever it is,
if you get out there
and do it yourself, people
are going to acknowledge
that you're, they're going
to acknowledge that effort.
I love to inspire people,
and I believe, you know,
my life is a testimony in itself
into speaking things into existence.
And you know, living' the dream,
and just kind of, you know, just
recognizing what you want to be
in life and achievin' it in that sense.
So, I just want to get out there
and kind of explain that.
And just, you know, you,
I'm an optimist, man.
And even in these times,
it's like you got to be able
to wake up with a smile and
go down feelin' really good.
I know it can get tricky at times.
I'm sure you guys are already discovering
how complicated like can be out there.
And it can really be hard on those dreams,
the things that you really feel like
you really want to accomplish,
but are really not in
your grasp right there.
So, I'm askin' you, please,
hold onto those dreams.
Never give 'em up.
Don't let go.
You going to hold on to 'em?
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
Are you going to hold on to 'em?
What is difficult at times,
is making sure it's perceived properly.
And you know because,
yeah, I have the ability
and the finances to be able to,
to produce, and direct, and
create what I want to create,
but then, now that I've done that
with my own finances, it's making sure
that it's a part of the community.
And that sometimes can
be an inner struggle,
but again, content is king.
Content will always win,
so it's all about what you
make and how you make it,
and the statement that it makes.
Recently we had the opportunity,
myself and, you know,
one of my mentors, Spike Lee,
created the film Chiraq.
And we did it in an unorthodox way,
you know, and Amazon was the
partner with Spike on that.
And we didn't go the traditional route,
and it got some amazing critical acclaim.
And a lot of attention.
♫ Leave high, everyday
♫ People die, everyday
♫ Arms high, everyday
♫ Fathers try, everyday
♫ Tryin' to get my head straight
♫ It's the city of Chiraq
♫ Come get your bed made
- Do you want justice?
- [Crowd] Yeah.
♫ Please pray for my city
- But, you know, a studio would
have never made that film,
and, or even, and it was a gamble
on how the world would perceive it.
And you know, Amazon took
that gamble with Spike.
But I feel like the more that
we do those type of things
and create opportunities, and step out
and say, yeah, we not going
to go the traditional route
where these four studios are allowed
to green light something.
We're going to do it on our own,
and we're going to partner with, you know,
and outside partner.
You know, assuming
partner that maybe isn't
normally considered to be,
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- A go to person in the music industry.
I mean, movie industry.
You got to step out there
and literally make something
out of nothing, create it.
If you want it, be it, live
it, walk it, generate it.
- Nice.
I'm claimin' it right now.
- Yeah, absolutely.
(laughing)
You got to.
- Do you think that that's
one of the keys to success?
Or it has been for you?
Just claiming it and
speaking into existence?
- Yeah.
Walkin' the walk, man.
Bein' about it, even, you know,
even that idea fakin' it til you make it.
I mean, that's what hip hop was built on,
- [Interviewer] Right.
- When you think about it.
You got to really step out on it.
And when others are going
to say nah, you can't do it,
say nah, it can be done.
It just hasn't been done before,
and I'll be the first to do it.
- [Announcer] The multi-talented host
of America's Got Talent
is about to put his hoop
skills on full display.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
So you be the judge for the rest.
Number One, Nick Cannon.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)
And the three time MVP at this event,
who proves everyday that
it's not the size of the dog
in the fight, but the size
of the fight in the dog,
(drowned out by cheering) Kevin Hart.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
(rock music)
(laughing)
♫ I don't want you
♫ To be a friend
♫ To work all day
♫ But I want you
♫ To want me
- Oh no, it's going to fall.
It's going to break.
♫ Just want to look after you
♫ After you
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
♫ Lookin' for some hot
stuff baby this evening
♫ I need some hot stuff baby tonight
♫ I want some hot stuff baby this evening
(whooshing)
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I made this video because
Patrick Reid asked me to.
If there's someone
you'd like me to profile
in the next Top Ten, check out the link
in the description and
go and cast your vote.
I'd also love to know what
was your favorite message
from this video?
What did you learn from this video
that you're going to
immediately apply somehow
in your life, or in you business?
Please leave it down
in the comments below,
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Mel Carpenter,
Mel thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and posting the interview
on your YouTube channel,
and a review on your blog.
I really, really, really
appreciate the support,
and I hope you enjoyed the read.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(whooshing)
- It's all about the mouth piece, baby.
Got to be able to talk the game,
talk like a boss, move like a boss.
Talk the hustle, that's what it all is.
So it all comes from me at least,
being able to speak things into existence,
and being able to talk
your way into any room
and talk you way out of any situation.
There it is, hustle up.
And, you know, I use
my age as an advantage,
but at the same time it
can be a disadvantage
in many different scenarios.
A lot of times people were saying, oh,
that's just a young kid doin' this,
or somebody who has some
money and doesn't really know
what to do with it.
So, sometimes I got to step
in and be a shark about it
and let people know that hey,
don't let the stuff that you know,
or that you think you know of me,
the TV shows, and all
that silliness fool you.
I'm a business man and I have
always been a business man.
My businesses are definitely
my life, my passion.
This is what I was born to do.
This is what I was
placed on the planet for.
(upbeat music)
I definitely consider myself
a small business owner.
And it starts with me.
Let's open up to four.
I have a strong consumer
electronic business,
which started in the world
of headphones and tablets.
Now we have a record label,
it's called Incredible.
My fashion brand is something
that I'm extremely excited
about, ties mean so much.
They stand for power.
I don't want to just be a
celebrity with a clothing line.
No, I want to learn the business.
I enjoy every aspect of
everything that I do.
My momentum is contagious.
It's a tidal wave.
When it comes, it comes crashing in,
and it takes over the entire room.
Can't stop us 'cause we always on the go.
(whooshing)